[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الشهر الخامس من شهور السنه الهجريه يسمى
بجمال اول ليش لان الماء كان يتجمد فيه من
شده البرد وقت التسميه فشهور العربيه كانت
تتوائم مع مسمياتها ربيع والربيع ثاني
دلاله على الخريف جماد ثاني دلاله على
الشتاء ورمضان رمض الارض اذا اشتدت
حرارتها وكان جماد اول يقع في موسم
الامطار الشتويه ولهذا يسميها العرب
القدماء بحنتم وهي السحب السوداء الماطره
كان الجو قاسي ما قاسي فصار سواده فيه
شحوب اقلب فيه اجفاني كاني اعود به على
الدهر
الذنوب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وجمادنا الاولى لهذه السنه جميع ايامه
داخله في حيز الموسم الاول الوسم الحسابي
واسم الوسم النص الثاني الوسم الواقعي
المربعانيه فالعشرين يوما الاخيره من موسم
سهيل والعشرين يوما الاولى من موسم
المربعانيه داخله في حيز الوسم وش معنى
هذا الكلام هذا معناه اذا نزل علينا مطر
خلال شهر جمادنا الاولى فانه منبتون لكل
شيء ففي اوله برد معتدل وهي مرحله جراند
عادي والعامه يقولون جراند
وفي نهايته بدايه البرد القارص وهو مرحله
بردى الانصراف فاذا انصرفت الشمس من جهه
الجنوب الى جهه الشمال فهذا اماره وعلامه
على بدايه البرد القارص والعامه يقولون
لها برد الا بعد
الانصراف
[موسيقى]